لولاية ثانية عام الفين واربعة
وعشرين. امريكا تتوعد الصين
بريف دير الزور في سوريا والذي
يعد اكبر قاعدة عسكرية للتحالف
علاقة انقرة بدمشق. يتصاعد
العداء بين تركيا واليونان وزير
بواشنطن الرافضة لبشار الاسد. ما
الذي سيفعله البيت الابيض يا ترى
اثارها على البلدين فقط فهذه
الخطوة ستؤثر على علاقة انقرة
الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد بعد
احدى عشر عاما من العداء
هناك من جحدر ليخلصنا من
الباسوس؟ نعم. فجحدر هو من قتل
الباسوس في مسلسل الزير سالم.
لنكمل. نعم. فبعد ان تعهد
بارمينيا امنة والديموقراطية
ومنطقة قوقاز مستقرة وامنة. اليس
بيلوسي تصب الزيت على النار
مجددا وتزور ارمينيا لعرض
الواحدة. الصين الواحدة. هل
تذهبي لتكمل الاندومي الخاص بك?
الحكومة الشرعية الوحيدة في كامل
الصين. الصين الواحدة الصين
فبكين لن تصمت وزارة الخارجية
الصينية صرحت انها تعارض بشدة
الله اسرائيل. والاخيرة تؤكد
جاهزيتها لاي سيناريو. قال
المنفذة للهجوم. عيننا وصواريخنا
على حقل كريش هكذا هدد حسن نصر
غزو صيني اجاب بايدن نعم نعم.
وكررها مرتين، لكن شبكة سي بي اس
على روسيا سيكون خطأ جسيما.
مضيفا ان هناك مؤشرات الى ان
توضيح ما اذا كان يقصد انه على
عكس الوضع في اوكرانيا ستقوم
بكين زودت موسكو باسلحة لغزو
اوكرانيا. وعند طلب منه المذيع
معه لن يكون مفيدا. سمع دوي سبعة
انفجارات داخل حقل العمر النفطي
وداعين للحفاظ على الهوية
المقدسة. الرئيس الايراني
اعدتها روسيا قبل غزوها
اوكرانيا. برأيكم هل ستكون خطوة
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن انه لم
يحسم بعد قرار ترشحه النهائي
بل حذر نظيره الصيني شي جين بينغ
من ان انتهاك العقوبات المفروضة
تايوان في حال تعرضها لغزو صيني.
هكذا قالها بايدن ولم يكتف بذلك
تصفع الصين. قوات الامريكية لن
تقف مكتوفة الايدي وستدافع عن
التعليم. واصرارا على التمسك
بالمنهج والمعارف الفلسطينية.
مدارس القدس الرافضة لمناهجها
التعليمية. الامر الذي دفع
باولياء الامور الى الخروج في
مظاهرات احتجاجا على اسرلة
الدولي بقيادة الولايات المتحدة
الامريكية فيما تعرف بعد الجهة
اخواننا في كابل مش حتقدر تغمض
عينيك. اسرائيل تسحب تراخيص
هكذا اصبح هكذا. وبعد ان كان لبس
الشرطية هكذا اصبح الان هكذا. مع
ابراهيم رئيسي الولايات المتحدة
لم تغير سياستها في الواقع.
لتقييم العسكريين المحترفين في
وزارة الدفاع الروسية. واشنطن
تطبيق التليجرام انه يمكن
للمناطق المختلفة على امتداد
الى حد غزو الاراضي اليونانية.
الاحداث والتطورات. طالبان تفرض
المساعدة العسكرية في مواجهة
اذربيجان. بيلوسي قالت ان
برأيي الشخصي. هو رد ضعيف جدا.
وماذا عن رأيكم انتم? هل هذا
المتحدثة باسم الخارجية الصينية
ماونينج. بكين تحتفظ لنفسها
بالحق في اتخاذ تراه مناسبا.
هناك صين واحدة في العالم فقط.
بالكامل من اجل استئناف عملهن
ببساطة بعد ان كان لبس المذيعات
المعارضين له. محاولات التقارب
بين تركيا وسوريا لن تقتصر
اردوجان بالوقوف مع اذربيجان ها
هو يبحث عن تجديد العلاقة مع
سريعا وعلى لسان المتحدث باسم
الكريملين قائلا نحن لم نصل للحد
زيارتها اشارة قوية الى التزام
الولايات المتحدة الراسخ
يعود من جديد. نعم. رمضان قديروف
اقترح عبر قناته الرسمية على
اشعلت النار بين امريكا والصين
قبل اسابيع ها هي الباسوس نانسي
سي ان ان اعتقد اننا فعلنا الشيء
الصحيح في الوقت المناسب. لو لم
الناتو بيل كلينتون الرئيس
السابق يكشف اليوم عن اخطر سر
واضاف الرئيس الامريكي السابق
الذي حكم منذ عام الف وتسعمائة
استمر في استونيا كيفية دعم
الحلفاء لاوكرانيا. وعلى ذكر حلف
تصريحات الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن بشأن تايوان. وقالت
بتدخل عسكري وشيك لا فيه. بينما
الجيش الصيني يعد العدة كما
على شرطيات ولاية هلمندا الملابس
السوداء التي تغطي اجسادهن
واستبعد ان نلتقي بالرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن لان التحدث
اليوناني نيكوز دندياس التهديدات
التركية لبلادنا غير مسبوقة وتصل
عندما يصبح اردوغان والاسد
صديقين مجددا؟ وبينما تتحسن
التي تمتلك المندوبة الامريكية
لدى الامم المتحدة ليندا تقول ان
حسب بيان رسمي نقلته مؤسسة
الطاقة النووية الاوكرانية
الكابيتال. الولايات المتحدة
الامريكية تزود اوكرانيا
الشرقية حال دون حدوث ازمة مبكرة
المنطقة. وقال في حديث مع شبكة
انريجو. ومن الخطر النووي الى
حلف شمال الاطلسي امني حيث اعلن
شريكا خاصا للناتو واعطاها عرضا
يتيح لها امكانية الانضمام اليه.
النووية دمرت على اثره اجزاء من
المباني الملحقة بالمفاعلات وذلك
حوالي خمسة الف فرد وهو ما يمثل
تقريبا جيشا كاملا. ليصل الرد
روسيا تجنيد الف متطوع من كل
منطقة وهو الحد الادنى الذي يجب
ان تفي به الكيانات. فيصبح
المجموع على المستوى القومي
الرد الصيني كاف واشنطن البسوس
تصب الزيت على النار. بعد ان
وتايوان جزء من الصين وحكومة
جمهورية الصين الشعبية هي
لتصبح الاسماك هي الضحية وترتفع
صادرات تون. مهلا مهلا مهلا.
مع روسيا. واضاف ان رؤساء
الاركان ناقشوا في مؤتمرهم الذي
نفعل ذلك لكانت الازمة قد حدثت
قبل ذلك. فقد رفضت روسيا حينها
بلادها ستواصل دعم اوكرانيا الى
ان تقرر روسيا وقف هجومها وسحب
وعلى بعد ثلاثمائة متر قصف كان
قريبا جدا من مفاعلات محطة
هكذا قالتها واشنطن سنقدم
لاوكرانيا انظمة ناسامس للدفاع
لتسبق واشنطن الحدث بخطوة. نعم
وبعد ان كانت تحمي اسوار البيت
وترقب اوكراني حذر يشير الى تسرب
استخباراتي عن رد روسي محتمل
واحدة لم تتغير. اخشى ان الرد
الصيني سيكون بمناورة عسكرية
عشر مليار دولار منذ بداية
الحرب. لا تفعلها لا تفعلها لا
نقلت عن مسؤول في البيت الابيض
ان السياسة الامريكية بشأن صين
القوات الامريكية بالدفاع
العسكري عن تايوان في حالة حدوث
محاولتهم شن على محور نيكولايف
كريفوي وبتصريحاته النارية ها هو
الدفاع الروسية مقتل اكثر من
مائتي عسكري اوكراني خلال
في تعابيره خرائط حروبه الحالي
والقادمة بايدن رد امريكا سيكون
تتعرض للقصف المباشر في هذه
الدولة. وانقرة تقول كلمتها
الاوكراني. وبعد ان اشعلت النار
بين امريكا والصين. ها هي
بوتين المقرب يفاجئ موسكو بهذا
الاقتراح. بينما واشنطن توجه
بكين القادمة اشبه بخطوات موسكو?
قواتها من اراضيها. البنتاجون
المساعدات لاوكرانيا تجاوزت خمسة
نجده شخصا اخر ذا طباع ملائكية
وفي الحرب يظهر بوجه اخر اظهر
الذي يستدعي ان نعلن عن التعبئة
الذاتية يجب ان يخضع ذلك اولا
رفضا قاطعا كون الروس لا يثقون
بالامريكان. وهنا اعلنت وزارة
بايدن الناتو يعرض على بوتين
الانضمام للحلف فبماذا رد بوتن
الابيض ها هي اليوم ترسلها
امريكا تحمي الاسوار الاوكرانية.
الجوي. نعم منظومة او الحصن
الواقي للبيت الابيض ودرع حماية
بحجم افعال روسيا في اوكرانيا.
تصريح ناري ياتي بعد هدوء مخيف.
يا ابن الكريملين. لننتقل للوجه
الاخر الوجه المجعد الذي ارتسمت
عن اكبر عملية اعادة هيكلة
لقواته العسكرية منذ اكثر من
دولي. نعم لقد قال انه اقترح في
عهده عرضا على روسيا ان تصبح
وثلاثة وتسعين حتى الفين وواحد
ان توسع الناتو في اوروبا
القبلات والاحضان بين الحضور
اعلى روحك العطرة والى خفة ظلك
مقطع فيديو الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين وهو متعجب من
سبعين عاما الحلف يتوسع ولكن
الحلف ليس مستعدا للدخول في حرب
صفعة موجعة لاصحاب العيون
الضيقة. والقواعد الامريكية
تفعلها. هكذا قالها بايدن ليقتل
الفضول بوتين ويقرر ان يفعلها
بالمنظومة الدفاعية لتصبح كييف
العاصمة الثالثة عشرة عالميا
الاخيرة بشأن التصالح مع بشار
الاسد. هدية بايدن لاوكرانيا. في
الباسوس نانسي بيلوسي تضع الرئيس
التركي حافة حرب جديدة وحليف
حينها وواشنطن تغضب الدب الروسي
بعد ارسال هذه الهدية للجيش
رد امريكا سيكون بحجم افعال
روسيا في اوكرانيا. هكذا قالها